بس بشكل عام كيف ترون مستقبل الحزن
قوه وحتى عبر هذا البرنامج الذي اطلقناه
منذ سنوات ليس فقط في جزء من البلد وانما
لكل ايطاليا وهو مشروع يعطي الاهميه
الاستقلاليه عده اقاليم
وينفذ ما ورد في دستورنا من تاكيد على
استقلال عده مناطق وهذا سيعني ليس فقط
تعزيز القدره الشرائيه وانما ايضا النجاح
في تعزيز الخدمات المقدمه للمواطنين عبر
التوافق موسعين للمرور من الدوله المركزيه
الى المناطق
طيب سؤالي الاخير
سيد فدريجه من فضلك كيف
او تعرف المنطقه التي تراسونها بانها
المثال الذي يحتذى به في كيفيه الحوكمه
وتحقيق النمو ما هي الوصفه لذلك في بلد
غير مستقر سياسيا وحتى اقتصاديا مثل
ايطاليا
راسها هي المنطقه التي نمت بشكل اكبر
وخاصه على مستوى الانتاج الزراعي خلال
2021 وهي الان نموا في كل ايطاليا وهي
المنطقه التي شهدت استقطابا اكبر
للاستثمارات الاجنبيه
اليوم لدينا العدد الاعلى للعاملين منذ ان
بدات الاحصاءات الوطنيه حول شغلي مواطن
العمل
وخفضنا الفريق بين الجنسين الى اقصى حد
ممكن وهذا بفضل الاستمراريه التي احنا في
تحقيقها وكما ذكرت كان هناك عدم استقرار
في البلد لكن هنا الوضع مختلف لانني كرئيس
منتخب مباشره من المواطنين وولايه مدتها
خمس سنوات فان هذا يسمح لي بتفعيل قرارات
على الميدان لصالح منطقه ما الى جانب ذلك
نحن اليوم نمتلك قدره على التعامل مع كل
دول وسط وجنوب اوروبا
انطلاقا من بناء اتريستي وكل بنيتنا
التحتيه وشبكه علاقاتنا مع كل اوروبا
فيولي فينيسيا جوليتنا فرصه لكليه الدول
ونحن نستقبل الكثير من الاستثمارات من
المانيا والنمسا والمجر وايضا تاتينا
استثمارات من وراء المحيطات لانهم يرون
الفرصه في فريون فينيسيا جوليا لتوسعه
استثماراتهم وتعزيز شبكه التعاون
اللوجستيك الدولي
مش انترنت عليهم الرئيس همم ماشي مليانو
افدريجا شكرا جزيلا لك على المشاركه معنا
في البعد الاخر 1000 شكرا